معظم حالات covid19 هي حالات
خفيفة أو معتدلة بدون أعراض ، ولكن حتى
في هذه الحالات يمكن أن يكون لفيروس كورونا
آثار دائمة
حتى بعد شهور من ظهور الأعراض التي أعانيها
تتطور باستمرار وأحصل على نفس الأعراض
مرارًا وتكرارًا ويبدو الأمر كما لو أن
المرء سيختفي نوعًا ما ثم
يأتي الآخرون  بعد
مرور أكثر من عام على انتشار الوباء
، لا يزال هناك الكثير مما لا نعرفه
عن الفيروس وكيف يؤثر على أولئك الذين
يصابون به ،
لكن رسالة بحثية جديدة نُشرت
في مجلة jama network open تقول إن
30 من أكثر من 175 مريضًا بفيروس كوفيد
المجموعة  أجريت أبحاثًا
على أن معظمهم يعانون من أعراض خفيفة ولم يكن هناك
علاج في المستشفى
لا يزال يعاني من أعراض مستمرة حتى بعد تسعة
أشهر ، وكان الأكثر شيوعًا هو
التعب وفقدان الرائحة
أو التذوق ، فنحن مثل الأربطة المطاطية التي نريد فقط
العودة إلى
ما كنا عليه  قبل ذلك ،
أعتقد أن هذا كان أحد أكبر
التحديات ، لكن إذا لم يكن الناس قادرين على
القيام بذلك واستمروا في الدفع ،
فعندما لا
تتحسن الأعراض  تعمل آرثي مع
أولئك الذين يعانون من أعراض ما بعد
كوفيد في مركز رعاية ما بعد كوفيد في نظام ماونت سيناي
الصحي
في نيويورك ، وتقول إن غالبية
مرضاها في العشرينات إلى الخمسينيات من العمر
ومع مرور الوقت والعناية
تتراجع الأعراض ، نرى المرضى
يتحسنون.
يقول الدكتور مكارثي البطيء تمامًا إن هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من البحث
لفهم
متلازمة ما بعد الطمع بشكل أفضل بما في ذلك فهم أفضل
لمن يصاب
بها وأفضل طريقة لعلاجها من أجل الصحة
الدقيقة أنا ماندي غايثر